what are we to make of these so-called
ghost ships or spy ships oh well there's
a lot of them I mean the Russians have
been doing this for years they have
ships which they say are survey ships
and fishing boats and normally they're
festooned with Aerials and interestingly
they don't make they never make much
pretends they're actually fishing they
don't even try to pretend that they're
fishing but they patrol around and these
sorts of things that have been spotted
in the Baltic now look as if they're
mapping the wind farms the offshore Wind
Farm facilities because obviously if
modern societies are going to take a
fair proportion of their power their
electricity generation from wind farms
in the future then they're vulnerable
and they could be put out of action it
could be destroyed it could be sabotaged
and we know that the Russians have
already got up to a fair bit of sabotage
in the Baltic Sea so these are credible
threats and the ships that operate up
and down off the off the British Coast
they carefully uh sort of position
themselves but what worries the British
and this goes back to 2017 the chief of
the defense staff then said in December
2017 we are very worried about undersea
cables because a lot of the undersea
cables that run the internet come in at
Land's End across the Atlantic it's
Land's End is where they they make
landfall in effect and those cables and
we worry quite a lot about the ability
to interfere with those cables destroy
them or even you know plug into them and
and draw stuff off them and what about
this cyber threat more broadly how
significant is that well again it's been
there for a long time but what Oliver
Darren was doing today I think is
recording the fact that the Cyber threat
is now General that what looked like
ransomware attacks so it looked like
criminal group attacks actually have got
a lot of political motivations behind
them and that happened in the the not
Petra Attack in 2016. it looked like a
ransomware attack but actually it was an
attack on the whole of the Ukrainian
government and it affected about 80
other countries including our own did
about 10 billion dollars worth of damage
so what what the things these attacks
are increasing and they are attacking or
potentially can attack Britain's
critical National infrastructure and
that's the that's the Target in in the
sort of war that the Russians are
fighting now against the rest of us if
they they can if they can attack the
critical National infrastructure they
can give the government something else
to worry about rather which is what it
approaches critical National
infrastructure great phrase isn't it
everybody says real critical National
infrastructure what is it well it is
defined by the British government as 13
sectors this is the British government's
list and that's arranged alphabetically
so chemical civil nuclear at the top and
transport space and water further down
and we've colored in there in light blue
those are the areas of these 13 sectors
in which the government has complete
control over defense emergency services
and government itself and in the dark
blue they they have you know heavy
involvement in health and space but in
all of the other sectors chemical civil
nuclear water food transport that's all
Private Industry it's all private sector
and a lot of that private ownership of
course in foreign hands and so
protecting the British national
infrastructure in these sectors depends
not just on what the government does but
what the government can persuade private
investors and private ball or boards run
by private investors to do effectively
to spend a great deal more money on
cyber security and to get on board with
a national resilience program we have a
resilience framework which came out the
end of last year and this resilience
framework aims to make the whole of the
UK much more resilient against amongst
other things organized Cyber attack